so today I want to make a very different
video than usual I'm going to explain a
puzzle that I made up and I'd love for
you guys to try and answer it in the
comments it's a bit silly but I found
this exercise really instructive even
though I already knew the answer in a
couple of weeks I'll upload a video
discussing the solutions you sent in so
here it goes
we work for a secret agency a large spy
network that will soon deploy many
agents to spy on the enemy we've decided
it's best if all spires work in teams of
two
however this poses some unique
challenges if a spy gets caught we can
pretty much assume that their partner is
caught as well and both will be
interrogated we need to decide how we'll
train the spies so that if they are
caught they reveal as little information
about the agency as possible for example
there are many other people spying on
the enemy so it would be good if the
enemy can't tell if our spies came from
us or not luckily for us we know a bit
about how the enemy interrogate and it's
quite weird they always ask each person
just one yes-or-no question and we know
that they only ever ask one of three
known questions they seem to pick which
one of the questions to ask randomly you
absolutely don't want the enemy to know
the right answer to any of these three
questions but you can't just get all
your spies to lie that's much too
obvious instead you've decided that the
best solution is if the answers are
random for example if we consider all
the spies who get caught and end up
being asked question one we weren't half
of them to say yes and half of them to
say no but remember our spies came in
teams the teammates get interrogated
separately and they may or may not be
asked the same question if they are
asked the same question they better give
the same answer otherwise the enemy will
know they're lying
of course it's tempting to give the
spies a way to communicate with each
other but the enemy makes sure that they
can't that said your spies can talk to
each other as much as they want
beforehand and they can bring as many
non communicating devices as they want
for example a coin or a copy of Mutants
book Principia so
your mission is to ensure that these two
things happen for each question on
average half the Spy's our state will
answer yes and half no and team members
if they're asked the same question
should give the same answer you're about
to start training your spires to make
this happen when your boss comes in and
tells you that she wants you to ensure
one more thing she says that you ought
to make sure that on average team
members only say the same answer half
the time just to explain this a bit
further you still need to make sure that
if your team members are asked the same
question they answer the same way but if
you look across all teams then you
should see half of the teammates saying
the same thing and half not you sputter
out that you don't think this is a good
idea but she insists that this will
ensure that the answers look extra
random so you decide to do two things
one you'll come up with a scheme that
meets all three demands but then two you
will convince her that if you use a
scheme like this then the enemy will be
able to tell that the spies are all
working together to trick them rather
than telling the truth so tell me how
you deceive both of these tasks you can
post solutions in the comments here or
I've set up accounts with these sites so
that you can post it on there if it's
easier remember this is not a
competition maybe it's best if you try
putting up a solution before you read
other people's it's fine if you're wrong
I got this wrong the first time
the idea is just to think about it keep
that in mind also when you comment on
other people's solutions so try it be
nice and good luck